hamiti dit bonjour c'est un ancien
timide qui vous parle vous êtes et année
on dit qu'à l'assurance quel aplomb
c'est pas possible que ce type là était
timide un jour est basse et j'ai été
timide comme vous je les ai eus votre
regard fuyant aux épaules basses
j'étais ridicule moi aussi comme vous
comme vous je tremblais comme une
feuille devant les gens je ne sais pas
m'exprimer je parle à voix basse jeu
susurrait mais plus maintenant car je
suis guéri je me suis soigné j'ai lu la
méthode des professeurs la folle et
chazot avec la paix de rennes ille et
vilaine ah non il m'a fait un nom pour
oser demander le livre jusqu'à ce que je
m'aperçoive que mon libraire est encore
plus timide que vous il était tellement
timide cet homme qui n'osaient pas
rendre la monnaie
il faisait semblant d'oublier alors
comme moi je n'osais pas lui réclamer je
faisais semblant de ne rien voir
on a des réactions curieuse quand on est
timide
moi j'en étais arrivé à ce point que je
n'osais plus regardé personne en face
même pas moi je me voyais dans une glace
je rougis sais et je n'ai tourné la tête
voyez comme c'est commode pour se raser
à l'hôpital ils l'ont dit à l'hôpital et
m'ont dit on va finir par manquer
d'agrafés ça nous fait alors j'ai lu la
méthode en question et je fais tous les
exercices
mais alors le plus difficile c'est le
dernier os le dernier ça c'était pouvant
table et seulement attention si vous le
faites bien vous êtes sûrs d'être guérir
il s'appelle ça le test de la gifle et
vous choisissez quelqu'un dans la rue
au hasard quelqu'un que vous ne
connaissez pas qui par conséquent ne
vous a rien fait et pan bougez-vous le
gifler et pas faut le faire remarquer
comme ils disent dans libre il ya 90% de
timides
vous n'avez donc pas neuf chances sur
dix pour qu'on vous la rendre vos chick
moi j'avais un petit peu tricher parce
que depuis quelques temps dans mon
quartier j'avais remarqué un jeune
garçon dès qu'ils me voyaient il rougit
c'est une bête c'est les yeux et rasait
les murs au je me suis dis toi mon
bonhomme tu es encore plus timide que
moi tu leur as pas valletta baigne
lendemain je le croise dans la rue pas
patte de torgnoles et ben il me les a
pas rendu vous savez ce qu'il m'a dit je
ne savais pas que vous étiez au courant
les gens disent n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi dans ces cas là quand j'ai raconté
ça à ma femme et à paris c'est curieux
n'apparut enfin moi ça y est je suis
derrière vous on vous pouvez pas rester
comme ça ah non non non il faut faire
quelque chose
alors écoutez vous allez suivre mon
conseil vous allez commencer par
l'exercice du regard appuyé vous allez
voir c'est très facile et en plus de ça
c'est rigolo l'exercice derrière appuyé
imaginez que vous êtes en présence de
quelqu'un qui vous impressionne je sais
pas moi votre professeur
votre chef de bureau à ministre
n'importe quoi bon vous non c'est pas le
regarder en face dans ces cas là vous
savez ce qu'il faut regarder sa
braguette et oui oui il va se dire il va
se dire ça y est elle est ouverte
il va être gêné est alors plus rager
n'est plus vous vous allez reprendre
contenance de commandes elle essayait
entre vous et vous allez voir c'est très
rigolo
essayez entre vous vous avancez très
précis c'est très amusant c'est le
verrou au fur et à mesure que lui va pas
perdre contenance
vous nous avez approuvé de certaines
assurances et bientôt cesser de de
bégayer et vous serez débarrasser
définitivement de cette envie
irrésistible que vous avez 2 2 fui